Speaker 1: . Let's go next to Felix from
Torrance. Felix from Torrance. Welcome to the
David Pakman Show. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: How you doing, David? Don't. Hey,
I got a question. I got a question, please. I
see more and more of these GOP. What they've
done. And what we all know is they they they have
tackled and they have they have taken social media
by storm, basically, compared to any Democratic
representative. Do you think this this at least
one Democrat that will start, you know, going on
Twitter and I know a few them do, but they they
don't do it as as aggressive as the GOP does.
Speaker 1: Felix I don't know that I know
what you're talking about. Who who on
the writer you talked to. So let's,
let's see if I can just ask a few questions. Are
you talking about Twitter specifically right now?
Speaker 3: Yeah, mostly it's way too correct
because the margins in the Greens and all
these like even Matt Gaetz, I mean when we
when we see these, these YouTube channels,
all they do is show their Twitter accounts.
They all these shows, what they wrote and what
they said. Right. And when do you think that
they'll ever be like a Democratic superstar
that just. I mean, AMC is probably as close as
I've seen. Yeah, it looks good on social media.
Speaker 1: I mean, Felix, one of the things that
you're kind of getting to is this is a structural
disadvantage for the left, and it's the following
disadvantage. The right's overly simplistic ideas
lend themselves to social media and short form
communication significantly more than the left's
ideas. And think about, you know, if you're on the
right, you can say taxes are theft. It's my money.
Let's keep it. Right. The left doesn't have an
equivalent because we on the left believe, listen,
we would all like to pay less, but if we're going
to have an organized and well-functioning society,
we do need to centralize some aspects through
government. And the way we do that is through
taxation. Which one of those two ideas, Felix,
lends itself better to Twitter? It's obvious it's
the shorter one, right? Correct. So I think that
this is something that has been a challenge for
the left for a very long time. I don't think it's
an insurmountable problem. I think we on the left
need to be better at that sort of pithy, short
form communication. But I don't think you're
wrong. I do think for now, the right certainly
is. It's a near-monopoly in some of these formats.
Speaker 3:
They grew much to. My pleasure. Yeah. Take care.
Speaker 1: All right. Felix from Torrance of.
Great to hear from you. Let's take a quick break
and the show will continue right after this